[Music]
hey what's up guys I'm Kip EHD here
YouTube rewind every year the biggest
celebration of of the top stuff on
YouTube that year the biggest creators
the best videos the memes everything at
least we thought a lot of people would
ask me about this you may have noticed
about a week ago YouTube rewind 2018 was
uploaded and it's not exactly doing - ha
in fact it's currently in just a few
days the second most disliked video ever
uploaded of all time first place being
Justin Bieber's baby and it's on pace to
pass that probably pretty soon so the
most outwardly hated video ever uploaded
to the site and it's all part of this
bigger overwhelming shift in sentiment
about YouTube rewind from the good old
days of 2013 2014 2015
till now but why why is this happening
that's the question naturally I think
the problem with YouTube rewind at least
as I see it is pretty simple actually
youtubers and creators and audiences see
it as one thing and YouTube who's in
charge of making it sees it as something
completely different so youtubers like
me and I've been in YouTube rewind
actually the past couple years now and
creators and and all of us tend to think
of YouTube rewind as this big
celebration of looking back at the
biggest youtubers the biggest YouTube
events things that happened on the site
in the past year and rewind just looking
back at it all makes sense right and
that is what it started out as actually
YouTube rewind 2011 the first one is
literally rebeccablack counting down the
top 10 most viewed videos on YouTube
that year ending in number one Friday
hip-fire Rebecca Black so this kind of
established it's like the whole point is
to rewind and look back at with the
biggest things on YouTube were and year
after year since then they've sort of
expanded it to include more YouTube
moments more memes more references and
it sort of became like this honor to be
included in YouTube rewind now this all
makes sense but at a certain point
YouTube started seeing it differently so
as YouTube as a site starts to grow and
expand you guys see from the other side
too
this with the scale and the massive
changes they obviously our company that
has to make money and the way they do
that is by pairing advertisers to
content so they started seeing YouTube
rewind as a place to showcase all the
best stuff that happens on YouTube for
advertisers and so now fast-forward to
this era of brand safety and post ad
pocalypse and all these things it's
become more important than ever for that
relationship between YouTube and
advertisers to remain strong and for
them to show the best stuff on the
platform to those advertisers so YouTube
rewind turned into this like hey check
out all these advertiser friendly things
for you to spend your money on all these
super clean creators and these
late-night show hosts and all these
things
that you want your ads next to you so
YouTube rewind in a way just turned into
a giant ad for YouTube that's the truth
so the Delta between what youtubers and
creators and audiences want rewind to be
and what YouTube it keeps making is
clearly why people are so upset everyone
has good reason to be mad about you know
big youtubers or moments that they
wished were in rewind for 2018 because
they were big on the platform but they
weren't in rewind PewDiePie Shane Dawson
the ksi versus Logan Paul fight just for
example some big things that happened
they were big in 2018 on YouTube and
they weren't in rewind but yet then you
have Will Smith Trevor Noah
John Oliver all not really youtubers I
mean Will Smith I guess at this point
sort of but also not all that really big
in 2018 specifically but yet they're all
in YouTube rewind 2018 for some reason
that reason being that that looks pretty
good to advertisers and then to top it
all off I think generally the style of
YouTube rewind has been sort of
difficult sort of problematic I think
even if they did include all these
things that everyone wants to see the
video was just it's just kind of hard to
watch and this is just coming from me
I'm just one guy and I happen to make
videos but YouTube rewinds not made by
one guy it's a production team so it's
made every year by a company called
portal a production company and YouTube
is the client
and they just try to shove everything
into this video every year and I think
that's the mistake like take a look back
I look backwards at YouTube rewind 2011
the first one it's two minutes long it's
Rebecca Black talking through the hits
of the year simple you know there's
there's a little montage in the middle
of some great moments the memes the
references it's great but it's one
creator and one song levels by Avicii
and then 2012 the next year so this is
the first year they actually brought
people in and creators in to shoot new
content instead of just bringing in
viral videos from that year and whole
video is a Gangnam style remix so if you
remember gangnams to hell the whole
thing it's four minutes long and
actually if you look at the credits this
photo is everyone featured in YouTube
rewind 2012 it's simple
you could catch everything you could
appreciate everything this was maybe
peak rewind as far as actual video style
if you ask me so then next year YouTube
rewind 2013 this is the year the first
year they tried to do a lot it's a
mash-up style it's six minutes long and
those six songs in the DJ earworm mashup
of the year there are 56 creators
there's also Cookie Monster and Jimmy
Kimmel but the rest were creators and
this is the first one that was produced
by portal a and if I had to guess this
is also the first year they started sort
of using rewind to share with
advertisers I think we you know the
community sort of gave this one a pass
because we liked it it was the sort of
first one of this style felt original
still felt like a sort of a celebration
of rewinding and looking back at YouTube
then there was rewind 2014 again a
mashup style 95 creators there are six
songs this time and lots of fast motion
and cutting to show more things just it
felt like they're trying to shove more
things in each time just absolute chaos
and then so on and so forth to YouTube
rewind
2017 which is just that the peak of it
all this is last year there's a bunch of
late-night talk-show hosts a bunch of
creators a bunch of traditional
celebrities etc it's seven minutes long
and a video is just flying it's just
this barrage of everything so when I was
20 18 I'm actually I was talking a bit
with the director as we were shooting it
in LA this year
and we were actually talking a bit about
how this year's rewind was gonna be
different actually before I even went we
were on a call about it but like they
talked about you know this year there
were hundreds 300 plus creators last
year this we were gonna cut it down to a
hundred we're listening to the comments
this is the first time we're gonna
actually give creators a voice in rewind
so it kind of felt like they were
getting something there it felt like
they understood that they have to cut
back a little bit the last one which was
the first one actually seemed to get a
bit of a negative reception wasn't
sustainable they got to cut it down and
actually fun fact I was told again this
was before we even shot this I was told
that they were planning on enjoying it
with Will Smith and when they met with
him about what he would have in rewind
apparently he independently said
fortnight and my name mkbhd I I can't
verify this
I want to believe but apparently that
was his own suggestion hey we'll if
you're watching this I would love to
collab
but apparently that's that's his own
idea but then I get there to the shoot
it's in LA I'm there all day for we're
shooting for 12 to 14 hours with a bunch
of other creators who were awesome we
did a bunch of takes of jumping out of
the fort night bus a bunch of different
expressions with everyone on the bus
everyone has different lines and
different things they're doing towards
the camera I did a stunt for a couple of
hours so yes me falling out of the bus
at the beginning of the video was
actually me harnessed in costume on like
a zip line actually falling past the
camera so that happened and there's a
whole clip on someone's hard drive
somewhere back at portal a of me like
landing in the bus realizing where I am
at like looking down at my costume
understanding that I'm on a bus and the
bus is flying and this is the fort night
bus and Will Smith put me here and
we're gonna have to jump is this what
you wanted it was all of that but then
the actual clip got cut down to this I
would want fortnight and marques
Brownlee is this what you wanted you
know who I would have asked for now is
it and like that's a cool clip and
everything I loved watching it but but
as someone who is there that clip didn't
convey the whole point of this shoot
it's just kind of all loss you barely
realize what's happening you maybe take
some of it in and then it's on to the
next scene and that's how it is with
every single clip it's just the montage
style all over again I'm sure if you
talk to other youtubers you know Casey
Liza other people who were in like these
four second clips they were probably
shooting for a whole day with much more
in mind and it all still ended up with
YouTube rewind 2018 this chaotic barrage
of clips that's just really hard to
watch so I think the the problem with
this mashup style rewind video in 2018
is you're still making it look like
you're trying to include everything when
you're also clearly still not including
everything so in conclusion YouTube
rewinds problem is it's trying to appeal
to advertisers because that's what
YouTube kind of feels like they have to
do by excluding any even little bit of a
controversial thing that happened in the
last year but in the mash-up style
they're still including hundreds of
things every single little thing they
can in an effort to try to make everyone
happy but the more things you include
the more obvious and well-defined those
exclusions are so YouTube you can't make
everyone happy I think like if anyone
could possibly fix rewind or make it
better for next year I think the change
you have to make is you got to leave
some stuff out you can leave me out I
don't mind obviously I've been in it for
a couple years and I love being a part
of it I learn a lot when I'm on the set
of the big of production like that and
it feels good to represent this sort of
tech community on YouTube that I think
is kind of underrepresented but you're
gonna have to leave some stuff out I
really think they should embrace cutting
stuff out and hand selecting the
sort of couple of things that really
popped and represented YouTube that year
and sort of a throwback to what made the
previous YouTube rewind so great just my
two cents either way I hope that video
helps sort of understand my perspective
as someone who was part of the
production I know a lot of people who
were in it aren't really saying much
about it but that's pretty much it
so thank you for watching and I'll catch
you guys in the next one a tech video I
promise bass